There has been a lot of buzz about Apple poaching engineers from Tesla...
...to work on a project rumored to be an automobile.
But Musk apparently doesn't care.
He told the paper that Apple is the "Tesla graveyard."
They have hired people we've fired.
If you don't make it at Tesla, you go work at Apple.
I'm not kidding.
Musk was pretty dismissive about Apple's rumored car plans overall,...
...saying, "Designing a car isn't like designing smartphones."
Despite what Musk says, he does seem a little agitated...
...about all the attention the company is getting from the electric car rumors.
Musk could be worried about a company with that much clout entering into the competition.
In the interview, Musk also touched on Tesla's profits or lack of profits.
He says he hopes the company will be profitable sometime in 2016,...
...but he won't adjust plans for growth just to turn a profit.
For Newsy, I'm Mikah Sargent.